let's start today with the prosecution
of Dr Anthony fauci which is not a thing
and it won't be and he won't be
prosecuted but it is a really
interesting sort of entry point or lens
into what the House of Representatives
has become under the control of
Republicans that started in January on
the basis of Republicans winning control
in November of 2022 not of the Senate
but yes of the House of Representatives
everything of note that the
republican-controlled House of
Representatives has uh involved itself
in publicly since they've taken over has
been a joke and in some cases has
actually backfired completely the
hearings on the a weaponization of
government humiliation just pathetic
humiliation the hearings about big Tech
and Hunter Biden and so on just an
embarrassment a global embarrassment to
the extent that the rest of the world is
paying attention to this nonsense but
importantly virtue signaling for the
small group of people that care
including the members of Congress that
treat hearings as a way to audition to
be on Hannity or Tucker's shows later
that day fine there is a sort of
persistent uh phrase that won't go away
from the Lexicon as my chair collapses
from the Lexicon of some on the right
which is prosecute fauci yes Dr Anthony
fauci now 82 years old has been working
for the government in a health role for
quite literally decades they want to
prosecute him and many of them are
saying forget about prosecute jail fauci
imprisoned fauci okay
why do they want to do that
I don't really know and we're going to
look at a clip of CNN's Jim Acosta
asking Dr fauci what do you think about
you know Elon Musk tweeting my Pro my
pronouns are prosecute fauci what do you
think about the people calling to
prosecute you and fauci says I don't
know what they would prosecute me for
the thing I wanted to ask you is you
know you've been vilified on the far
right I know you know that yeah um and
we've seen Elon Musk tweet that his
pronouns uh he's the owner of Twitter
that his pronouns are prosecute uh
members and the GOP have talked about
arresting you and Prosecuting you
um for your handling of code what's your
response to that your response to musk
and what has that been like for your
family yeah
well I mean there's no response to that
craziness Jim I mean prosecute me for
what what are they talking about
I mean I wish I could figure out what
the heck they were talking about I think
they're just going off the deep end yes
that's the answer to your first question
it doesn't make any sense to say
something like that and it actually is
irresponsible of course it's going to
have a difficult effect and a
deleterious effect on my family I mean
they don't like to have me getting death
threats all the time every time somebody
gets up and spouts some nonsense that's
misinformation
disinformation and outright lies
somebody somewhere decides they want to
do harm to me and or my family so that's
the part about it that is really
unfortunate the rest of it is just
Insanity the things they're saying but
it does have a negative effect when
people take it seriously and take it out
on you and your family which is the
reason why I still have to have
protection which is really unfortunate
it's not only unfortunate that Dr fauci
needs security at this stage of the game
or at any stage to the game it's insane
that the right has allowed themselves to
be led down this absurd path wherein a
doctor who simply is trying to do what's
best to most uh uh to save and help the
largest number of people possible
has become not only the target of like
oh he might have been wrong about
certain things at certain points oh okay
all right well we could talk about that
but this is a criminal this is an evil
person he created covid which is one
that's been floating around and of
course that he should be prosecuted now
let's play it out
out of curiosity I did some research to
try to figure out what exactly do they
want Dr fauci prosecuted for I don't
know how many of you know this I mean if
if I before I tell you what would you
guess they want him prosecuted for it
seems that the most common refrain is
fauci should be prosecuted for lying to
Congress which is not really a
mishandling of covid particularly when a
lot of these very same right-wingers
said that you know all of the Trump
people prosecuted for lying either to
Congress or investigators that's not
really a crime well now they want fauci
prosecuted for that but what was it that
fauci said that they say is a lie well
when Dr fauci said the federal
government has not funded gain of
function research at the Wuhan Institute
for virology
these right Wingers say that that was
lying to Congress under oath and worthy
of prosecution well what's the truth of
that it's a very shaky basis for
prosecuting first of all scientists
aren't in agreement as to whether what
was happening as to whether the research
being done is really gain of function
gain of function is a general term and
you can find scientists who will
disagree as to whether
any gain of function research was being
done at the Wuhan Institute of virology
that's number one number two
even if gain of function research was
being done at the Wuhan Institute of
virology
what they're referring to is an NIH
Grant recipient and I called Eco health
and the issue is that Eco Health did not
file a report about what they were doing
which is their fault ecohealth is in the
wrong because they didn't file a report
saying what exactly they were doing but
that certainly suggests that at minimum
when Dr fauci said what he said under
oath he believed that he was telling the
truth even if it turns out that there
was gain of function research being done
to the satisfaction of every Medical
Science professional which there is not
there is every reason to believe that Dr
fauci believed he was telling the truth
when he was under oath I can assure you
there will be no prosecution over that
and it relates to the same reason that
you rarely see prosecutions for perjury
uh for Witnesses in criminal trials
Witnesses in criminal trials say things
that aren't true all the time and it is
extraordinarily difficult to prove that
they knew they were saying things that
were false and that's why you very
rarely see a perjury prosecution so
that's what it is if you're wondering
wow prosecute fauci what is that all
about this is what it is all about and
Dr fauci is confused as any of us as to
why resources would be spent in that way
but they want to do the hearings they
want to bring fauci down they want to
make the whole dog and pony show happen
I expect that they will
but there is not going to be any
prosecution of Dr Anthony fauci and
that's a good thing
um listen we we have a problem in this
country
the problem we are told by you probably
knew that the problem we are being told
by everybody from neo-nazis to White
lives matter people to the proud boys to
all sorts of other unaffiliated
right-wing activists is that the problem
is drag shows drag queens drag time
story hours
and that sort of thing now I have video
to play for you today
of an event uh at a drag show at a
public park in Wadsworth Ohio I have
video here from Ford Fisher from news to
share and what you will see is that
those who are against the drag show and
decided to protest are pretty horrible
people including
gun-toting neo-nazis which you will see
the Patriot front White lives matter so
on and so forth these are the folks who
were really really upset that children
if their parents choose to might be
brought to a drag show take a look at
this
[Applause]
so by the way there's a guy with a gun
and a swastika flag right on if you're
listening right now that's the first
thing we're seeing here and of course uh
this is you know as a parent myself if
you say to me what am I most interested
in keeping my daughter away from drag
time story hour
or gun-toting neo-nazis with swastikas
the answer is pretty clear to me my
friends
Zig Heil is where we are right now
[Music]
they're yelling pedophiles get something
[Applause]
[Music]
okay that's probably enough now as you
can tell these are merely people
expressing economic anxiety because of a
middle class that has been left behind
right right no uh this really does this
really does go to show that this is not
about all of the innocent things that
many on the Republican right have
started to say you know this they very
often will say you know these right-wing
movements they are here because the
Democratic party has left the middle
class behind and they're suffering
economic anxiety and they're worried
about jobs being offshore to China and
Mexican immigrants documented or
undocumented taking their jobs or
whatever the case may be this is not
about any of that
this is about retrograde
outdated
hysterically backwards beliefs
and
the desire
to bring those beliefs into public into
public View
partially as a result of the
normalization of this type of stuff
dating back most acutely to the Trump
presidency now I know I've said it
before I don't believe Trump created
racism I don't believe Trump created
white supremacy or neo-nazism of course
he didn't but what Trump did do is he
made a lot of the people who already
believe those things more comfortable
uh espousing those views in public and
when you look at CPAC today
when you looked at CPAC last year and we
noticed the biggest Applause lines were
the transphobic stuff and the homophobic
stuff and the oh marxists there's
marxists which of course there are very
few marxists in the United States
that is part of the coddling of these
sorts of views where people end up being
comfortable coming out now a lot of
these people clearly aren't that
comfortable because they're wearing
masks and
um if they were really confident and
comfortable in espousing these beliefs
publicly they wouldn't wear the masks
and of course I'm sure many of them
would end up getting themselves fired
but that's not the situation and again
just just remember that at the core of
this is
drag shows
which parents might choose to bring
their kids to or maybe not but we're
talking about parental Choice parental
rights which is what these right-wing
groups claim to be all about well let
parents make their choices then don't
shut down the drag event allow parents
who like it to bring their kids and
allow parents who don't like it to bring
their kids somewhere else but no all of
a sudden that freedom to parent goes
away when they decide we're going to
show up with the guns and with the
swastikas in order to try to shut this
thing down if you're just listening
today the clip I played will be on our
YouTube channel on our Facebook page on
our Instagram you can find it there make
sure you are subscribed to the YouTube
channel and make sure you have liked
this video if you are watching on
YouTube we'll take a quick break and be
right back one of our sponsors today is
Bon charge I have always enjoyed dry
saunas you get in there your heart rate
is up dilates the blood vessels can
soothe achy joints and muscles it's
relaxing it's just a great way to remove
a little stress Bond charge is the
creator of the infrared sauna blanket
which you can enjoy from home super easy
to set up heats up fast you don't have
to have your head inside like at a
traditional sauna at the gym nice for
meditating or reading getting work done
relaxing I have found it to be a great
way to unwind at the end of a long day
easy to clean Sleek lightweight design
easy to store and comes with a 12-month
warranty and of course if you don't love
it returns are super easy but I think
you will love it go to boncharge.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman 15 for 15
off the link is down below
hey remember that our program does
depend on your support so that we can
continue doing what we do and one of the
best things as my chair what I think
that by the end of the show I actually
may fall off the chair the chair is
collapsing very very rapidly
um one of the things we need a new chair
and this is why membership is so
important no it's something I we did a
little bit of a
renovation a little bit of a cleanup of
the studio over the weekend and clearly
some some I believe antifa might have
sabotaged my chair we'll look into that
no in all seriousness we do what we do
and we do it free of me having 10
editors and and Executives telling me
cover this or don't cover that or
perpetuate the big lie or whatever's
been going on on Fox news we're free
from all of that because our primary
source of funding is people from the
audience as much as I love Jill from
North Dakota and Bob from Tennessee and
all of this none of them are going to
write to me and convince me to do a
story differently or whatever the case
may be right and and this is the sort of
point of spreading our support across as
many people as possible we remain in
control not some big Corporation or
executive and to that end
you can sign up at joinpakman.com it's
really cheap it's really simple we do an
extra show every day for our members and
you can use the coupon code 24 starts
now to get yourself a discount off of
the cost of membership Glenn Younkin did
a very very stupid thing he agreed to do
a town hall on CNN and it went so bad so
quickly that I can only imagine he and
his uh staff afterwards said why the
hell did we do that let's look at a
couple of clips and remember the context
of Glenn young can becoming governor of
Virginia was that he ran
against critical race theory he sort of
ran like an issues-free anti-woke
campaign critical race Theory wasn't
even being taught in Virginia schools
and yet it was enough for him to win so
there was very little substance in
getting him to be governor and there
remains very very little substance in
his explanations about how he's running
Virginia and why he's running Virginia
in that way so at one moment during the
event a student who identifies as a
trans man asked Glenn youngkin listen uh
which bathroom should I be using in your
view in your view about all of these
issues of trans and gender and whatever
now I dare you to find an actual answer
from Glenn Younkin in this video uh
Governor youngin your transgender model
policies require that students play on
the sports teams and use the restrooms
that correspond with their sex assigned
at Birth look at me I am a transgender
man do you really think that the girls
in my high school would feel comfortable
sharing a restroom with me
yep so first of all Nico thank you for
again asking the question being here
tonight and engaging in this important
discussion
I believe First when parents are engaged
with their children then you can make
good decisions together and I Met Your
Dad and I'm glad that you're both here
together that's really really important
thank you for being here I'm aware that
your father is here okay great but like
what bathroom should Nico use
I also think that there are lots of
students involved in this decision and
what's what's most important is that we
try very hard to accommodate students
that's why I have said many many times
we just need extra bathrooms in schools
we need General neutral bathrooms and so
people can use a bathroom that they in
fact are comfortable with
I think sports are very clear and I
don't think it's controversial I don't
think that biological boys should be
playing sports with biological girls uh
there's been Decades of efforts in order
to gain opportunities for women in
sports and it's just not fair
um and I think that's pretty that's
that's non-controversial and something
that I think is is pretty well
understood now here is Nico's dad
shaking his head at this again I think
these are very difficult discussions and
I am very very glad to see you and your
dad here together right it seems the big
thing is that Nico and Nico's dad are
both there that seems to be the thing
Glenn youngin most wants to talk about
so let's talk about this okay first of
all Junkin says the priority is that
people should be comfortable well then
Nico should be using the men's room
right because it's abundantly clear that
Nico would be most comfortable in the
men's room then he goes into this thing
of well the bathroom should be gender
neutral as as a complete and total
cop-out now I don't disagree okay I I
think the gender neutral bathrooms are
great this has been a thing in Europe
for a very very long time it's fine to
do gender neutral neutral bathrooms but
Virginia has thousands of public schools
and they don't even have money for extra
pencils for teachers okay the idea that
we're going to solve this in Virginia by
converting thousands of bathrooms to
gender neutral rather than actually
dealing head-on which with with which
bathroom Nico should use is absolutely
laughable now I've said this before and
this is a real practical question I
don't know how many of you are familiar
with Blair white or Chaz Bono
um the idea that what is logical and
what would make everybody the most quote
comfortable under their view is for
Blair white who was born biologically
male to use a men's room today is wacky
just Google a picture of Blair white on
the same hand on the other hand on the
same token the idea that Chaz Bono or
Bono who was born biologically female is
a trans man should today be using a
women's room again if we want to use
their Paradigm about what's most
comfortable visually based on how people
look that's absurd
so there's really a bigger issue here
which junkkin doesn't actually want to
address and this was about how the
entire town hall went there was another
moment where
um Junkin was asked about his view about
removing books for school libraries any
similarly dissembled and talked around
the issue and didn't didn't really dig
into what's actually at issue here so
my whole approach to this starts with
with snow what's in the library and
parents understand what materials are
being used in the curriculum
and so last year we were able to pass a
bill in a bipartisan basis that gave
Parents full visibility into materials
in the classroom Now understand
this this mostly already exists so even
even this is a distraction well as a
first step parents need to know what's
in the library and what's being taught
in their kids classes but what's
preventing them from doing that and I
know there are people who will say well
yeah you know it's hard to get out of
kids you have you tried talking to a 12
year old 12 year olds don't want to talk
to their parents they won't tell you
okay no that may be but there is nothing
that prevents parents from going to the
school library and looking around or
from emailing the teacher or whatever
the case may be so this entire thing we
formalize that there's going to be
transparency there basically is unless
there's a rare situation going on or
special circumstances there's
transparency already it's not actually
getting at the issue of banning books
and if those are sexually explicit
materials that aren't consistent with
family values then a parent can request
a replacement a replacement material
into their child's curriculum
see I do believe that there's moments
where we have to make decisions about
what's age appropriate and what is
appropriate and those are hard decisions
but we should run away from them we
should engage in them and these are
healthy discussions for us to have what
this of course ignores and in a way it's
similar to the issue of abortion what it
ignores is just because decisions have
to be made that may be difficult books
that are edge cases for an
eight-year-old for example or does a
pregnant woman want to get an abortion
just because they were difficult
decisions or even morally complex or
philosophically ambiguous or whatever
the idea that it's the government that
should be making those decisions is
being accepted as a foregone conclusion
by folks like Glenn youngin and others
who want to get involved in curriculum
well if the decisions have to be made on
abortion they should be made by medical
professionals as well as the impact
individuals in particular the pregnant
woman if we're making decisions about
books then shouldn't those decisions be
made by teachers and Educators rather
than by Glenn Younkin and whoever he
parted in a partisan way deputizes but
they ignore that as a reality what books
should be in an elementary school
library should they have explicit
pictures in them or not well I don't
think there should they should be there
but it's not really Glenn youngin's area
of expertise and these are decisions
that I think we should take on as
opposed to run away from yeah the the
problem is who he wants taking it on so
all of this just Babble Babble Babble
and then one more interesting clip here
where uh Jake Tapper actually gets into
it with youngin about how history should
be taught in school exactly you ask you
about that which is kind of following up
on what Brock was asking because you're
you're executive order that ended the
teaching of CRT said that it would end
the teaching of inherently divisive
Concepts including CRT so other than CRT
can you give us a specific example of
what is an inherently divisive concept
well no I only ran against CRT Jake I'm
not informed about anything else that
you think should not be taught in
Virginia schools yeah the inherent the
inherently divisive concepts are taken
directly from the Civil Rights Act
and they're teaching children that
they're inherently biased or racist
because of their race or their sex or
their religion they teach that a child
is guilty for sins of the past because
of their race or their religion or their
sex they teach that a child is is
oppressed or a victim because of their
race the religion or their sex now
remember that there's two parts to this
one even though I have my problems with
critical race Theory and other critical
theories
doesn't mean that he's accurately
representing what they teach that's
number one
um and then number two
this wasn't being taught in Virginia at
all the fact that whether what he's
saying about CRT is accurate or not it
wasn't being taught in Virginia schools
and of course we've seen this in
curriculum you see critical race Theory
isn't a class that's taught it's
something that is it's a philosophy
that's Incorporated in the curriculum so
and we saw it in Fairfax County with
privileged Bingo and games like this but
we also saw it in teacher training and
professional development and recommended
books and this is how they are now
sliding around the fact that this isn't
being taught which is by saying well
it's being implicitly integrated as a
philosophy and of course there are
dozens of witnesses that have said that
is absolutely not the case and it is not
what is going on in Virginia schools so
you have to understand when you build
your campaign on nothing you end up if
you ever do a town hall confronted with
the reality that there's no there there
and you're completely unable to
substantive we actually talk about
anything and that's the way this entire
town hall went I would say check out the
entire thing but quite frankly I don't
think it's worth it but not a
particularly good performance by Glenn
Younkin and even though his name is
being tossed around as a possible
presidential Contender it's not looking
really really good
speaking of Governors running for
president
did you know that it's actually against
the law for Ron DeSantis to run for
president unless he resigns his
governorship there is a Florida law that
forces Governors to resign if they want
to run for president of the United
States so what is Ron DeSantis going to
do well it's looking like Republicans in
Florida are looking at changing that law
specifically so that Ron DeSantis could
remain Governor while running now you
might say but David I remember that Jeb
Bush remember the please clap guy Jeb
Bush was governor and he ran for
president that's true
but Jeb Bush was not Governor at the
time that he was running for president
he had previously been a governor so
let's take a look at an article that
explains what's going on wfsu public
media reported a couple months ago
Florida leaders are considering a change
to the resign to run law to help
Governor Ron DeSantis Ronda santis may
need some help from the state
legislature if he proceeds with this bid
for the Republican nomination a resigned
to run Law requires State office holders
to commit to leave their positions if
they run for federal office this has
been on and off the books over past
decades and was reinstated in 2018 but
Republican leaders in the Republican
dominant dominated legislature have
expressed openness to changing or
rescinding it when they gather again in
March that's this month Florida house
Speaker Paul Renner told reporters it
was a quote great idea to review the law
Senate President Kathleen pasodomo
similarly said changes to the
resignation requirement would be a good
idea if an individual who's a Florida
Governor is running for president I
think he should be allowed to do it now
DeSantis for now has a way around this
and you know one of the things we've
been talking about has been is DeSantis
actually going to announce is he really
planning to run and it seems the answer
is yes because of all of the events he's
doing in critical early voting States
but when is he going to announce part of
the reason he may delay the announcement
at least until April is that this month
Florida is going to meet about this
resign to run law in the meantime the
way DeSantis can sort of like start
running is by doing all of these stops
Under the Umbrella of being book tour
events but really they are early
presidential type events in fact Fox
News had an article this morning about
how Rhonda Santos has already been to
Iowa and he's been to Nevada and now
he's going to New Hampshire so these are
in practice presidential campaign type
events but for now and it may only be a
matter of a few more weeks Ron DeSantis
would have to resign in order to run for
president Florida's looking at changing
that clearly and specifically for Ron
DeSantis so we're going to follow that
let's talk about the Florida miracle
anybody know what that is no I don't uh
this is a really funny clip and this is
all part of Fox News helping Ron
DeSantis even though he has not declared
yet that he is running for president Fox
News is helping create the image that
Florida is a miraculous State now I
don't actually know what the miracle is
but here is Maria Bartiromo quite a
prominent Trump brown-noser but remember
everybody on the right is realizing
DeSantis might have power here
uh let's at least get on his good side
here is Maria Bartiromo helping Rhonda
santis promote the Florida Miracle let's
see if we can figure out what that
Miracle is talk to us about the Florida
miracle and what you see happening for
the country if in fact it takes on this
item yeah
well I think as you know because I come
on your show I mean we were getting
hammered by the left by the corporate
press uh by bureaucrats like fauci every
step of the way during covid whether it
was businesses being open people working
having activities kids being in school
and you know I really took a lot of
incoming even a lot of my supporters
were telling me man you're getting
killed uh you're you're really going to
be put out the pasture here politically
unless you do something different but I
just had to look and say you know what
my job as a leader is to put the
interest of the people I represent and
their jobs over my own interest and
keeping my own job and so if there's
short-term political pain and ultimately
if it doesn't work out for me
politically that's fine yeah so I guess
the miracle that Maria is talking about
based on on desantis's response is that
in the middle of the pandemic DeSantis
opened some sporting events including
wrestling and UF see and pass the don't
say gay bill right I mean like what
what's the Florida miracle that they're
talking about now I will I will be very
upfront
I think Florida is great and I spend
quite a bit of time in Florida
particularly in those liberal counties
down on the tip there as people refer to
it but the weather is great the food
scene is great I love the people there's
a big Argentinian Community there
there's a big Jewish Community there in
Southern Florida that's all great but
the truth is that if you zoom out and
look at the entire state
Florida is a pretty damn mediocre State
and what I mean by that is it's not a
particularly great state by any metric
and it's not a particularly terrible
state by any metric but calling it a
miracle is weird Health Care is ranked
25th in Florida all right it's right in
the middle infrastructure is ranked 20th
in Florida crime is ranked 26th in
affordability Florida is 33rd there's
overall pretty good quality of life if
you have money in Florida and also if
you don't a lot of the metrics really
are lacking like it's just unremarkable
there's no big Florida story other than
the mediocrity that is the state of
Florida sad DeSantis put kids back in
school faster than some other states
open sporting events with audiences
during covid faster than some other
states
some people liked it some people didn't
like it but that's it they're turning
what is a complete non-story into a
quote Miracle according to Maria
Bartiromo and it's because it's not
about the fact it's about narrative and
the idea of the narrative that's being
created is one that actually
distinguishes DeSantis from Trump and
remember this is a big thing where Nikki
Haley is asked to distinguish herself
from Trump she doesn't say anything
other than I'm younger I'm a woman and
I'm Indian that's how she's playing uh
identity politics DeSantis even though
again on policy he's almost identical to
Trump he is also trying to create some
difference and part of that now is I
bucked what was happening federally on
covid
and opened up sporting events and sent
kids back to school earlier is that
going to convince Republican voters I
don't know I'm not one of them but I
guess we'll have to wait and see this
clip and others from today find them on
my Instagram by searching Instagram for
David Pacman show
despite claiming that he never thinks
about Ron DeSantis failed former
president Donald Trump is clearly
obsessed with Ron DeSantis and that
obsession is starting to become very
very unhealthy it is abundantly clear
and it is supported by the fact that
Donald Trump sees Ron DeSantis as
potentially his most powerful Challenger
in the 2024 Republican primary now Ronda
sandis still hasn't announced that he is
running we talked earlier in the show
about why that might be and when his
announcement might be coming if indeed
he plans to make that announcement
Donald Trump is posting daily to his
platform truth social about Ron DeSantis
I hope that anybody who is planning on
following the 2024 election is prepared
for more than a year of what we saw over
the last four days take a look at some
of these childish and ridiculous posts
from the failed former president who's
nearly 80 years old this is not a kid
that we're talking about first posting
about the size of Ron desantis's
crowd quote very small crowds for Ron de
sanctimonious and Iowa he's against
capital F Farmers Social Security and
Medicare so why would people show up
other than capital F fake stories from
the capital F fake capital N news the
random capitalization and the lies both
Staples of Donald Trump's posts as we
talked about before
attacking DeSantis on Social Security
and Medicare is a little shaky given
Trump's own history with submitting
Federal budgets that would cut Social
Security okay then Trump goes on to
comparing his book to Ron desantis's
book posting quote summon the fake news
are falsely stating that Ronde
sanctimonius's book is doing as well as
letters to Trump my new book this is
fake news in that letters doesn't even
come out until April 25th Ron has groups
buying his book in order to inflate
sales and in fact on the first day his
book was already 30 percent discounted
letters to Trump has much different
pricing and is a coffee table book the
so-called Stars corresponded with me
you'll love it pre-order the book so
couple different things there of course
Donald Trump just obsessed with
comparing the size of all of his things
to that of Ron DeSantis and Trump is not
mentioning that Don Jr's book also
benefited from groups buying the book
this is actually a really common thing
it's particularly common on the right
although maybe it does happen on the
left as well but when large right-wing
figures whose followers barely read I
mean let's be let's be really really
honest with each other here do you think
the average Don Jr follower reads books
where would you put the over under on
the number of books the average Don Jr
follower reads and I hate folks that
this is it sounds so a Leo but David
reading oh but come on Trump himself
hasn't read a book in his adult life and
we're supposed to pretend Don's fault
Don Jr's followers read books Don Jr's
book benefited greatly
from people groups buying the book and
then giving it out when Don Jr speaks
and this sort of thing okay then Trump
continuing to be obsessed with
um Ron DeSantis posts the results to a
meaningless online poll about 2024 where
15 000 people click the button online
and said they preferred to Santa they
prefer Trump to DeSantis by two to one
now I I believe Trump is winning uh but
Trump just put posting garbage polls and
then Trump posting quote Ron de
sanctimonious totally caved in his
public relations inspired battle with
Disney the that's the only reason he
went after them in the first place to
show Mr tough guy Disney maintained
complete exemption from property and
sales tax tax-free bonds and their
incredible Fast Track permitting they
also gave big political contributions to
Des Sanctus the whole thing is a capital
H hoax they probably work together to
make them look like a fighter read Rick
fogle'song preeminent Authority on
Disney I could keep going back to last
week but I won't
this might be the most childish and
ridiculous primary that we ever see and
meanwhile on the Democratic side there
may be no primary if Joe Biden runs for
re-election which some people say isn't
good there are people on the left who
say forget about its impact on the
general the Democratic party should have
a real primary if there are people
challenging Joe Biden there should be a
real primary and there should be debates
and so on and so forth there uh I
understand that perspective and we're
going to talk about that more maybe a
little bit later this week or maybe once
we we hear from a couple other
candidates who plan to declare but Trump
obsessed unhealthily with Ron DeSantis
one more Trump thing I want to talk
about Donald Trump posted and endless
back-to-back truth statement on his
platform truth social truth essential
yeah and
it is absolutely absurd and it relates
to the Stormy Daniels Affair and it also
relates to Donald Trump's impending
indictment or indictments that Global uh
that legal Scholars increasingly believe
are coming I'm not holding my breath but
there are legal Scholars who believe the
indictments are coming take a look at
this insanity this is multiple truths
okay this was over the weekend this is
Trump now I'm I'm speaking As Trump I
did absolutely nothing wrong I never had
an affair with Stormy Daniels nor would
I have wanted to have an affair with
Stormy Daniels that's a lie now is he
saying is this a semantic argument I
didn't have an affair with her but I did
engage in sexual relations with her he
did pay her off for her silence so why
would you do that if you didn't it
doesn't make any sense so he's already
lying he says this is a political Witch
Hunt trying to take down the leading
candidate by far in the Republican Party
while at the same time also leading all
Democrats in the polls including Joe
Biden and Kamala Harris Congress and
numerous Democrat District Attorneys
Attorneys General and thee then it
continues on another truth Department of
Injustice itself which has
unprecedentedly placed top doj
prosecutors into the Manhattan District
Attorney's Office in order to quote get
Trump have found that I did nothing
wrong
that's not true by the way there were
prosecutors who were convinced Trump did
do things wrong but that nobody was
going to indict him and those
investigators quit back to Trump now
they fall back on the old and rebuked
case which has been rejected by every
prosecutor's office that has looked at
this Stormy horse-faced Daniels matter
where I Rely relied on counsel in order
to resolve this extortion of me which
took place a long time ago since then I
have won lawsuits continuing on to
another Truth for hundreds of thousands
of dollars against Stormy Daniels and
every prosecutor's office which has
looked at it which are numerous
including the FEC have turned this fake
case down this is not a state case it is
a federal case and they have all passed
on it even the previous Manhattan D.A
Cyrus Vance did not bring charges
because I am guilty of nothing except
for the fact that I am beating all
Republicans and Democrats badly in the
presidential race it is Russia Russia
Russia Ukraine Ukraine Ukraine the no
collusion Mueller hoax and other
targeted false attacks against me all
over again it is a weaponization of our
judicial system and I am shocked that
this soros-backed radical left
prosecutor who has allowed violent crime
to reach New Heights in New York without
any retribution would consider bringing
such a charge against the Undisputed
front-runner of one of the two major
political parties in our Capital land
Nation
folks I'm out of breath but this is
insane this is a completely insane
statement to put out it's it's a
Rorschach test it's a verbal ink plot
Additionally the statute of limitations
has long since ended and in fact radical
left media one and a half years ago did
a countdown on the statute of
limitations which was allowed to expire
the countdown ended until now nobody had
any idea it was allowed to continue in
this one low ball office
it is appalling that the Democrats would
play this card and only means that they
are certain that they cannot win at the
voter Booth so they have to go to a tool
that has never been used in such a way
in our country weaponized law
enforcement
now about by the way
um it's prosecutors and investigators
that would be doing this Democrats
aren't doing anything
Trump continues I and hundreds of
millions of the American people who are
backing me Trump doesn't have hundreds
of millions of backers by the way
because they want to see our nation be
great again are the victims of this
corrupt depraved and weaponized justice
system where Hunter Biden and his father
can commit horrendous crimes all
accurately documented on his laptop and
nothing happens but with me after
looking at 11 million Pages worth of
documents they go after a hoax that
every other prosecutor's office which
reviewed it and even the U.S Congress
has long ago dropped I will not be
deterred I will always continue to be
your voice and I will keep fighting for
our great Capital C country
this is what we are to expect if this
continues and Donald Trump's candidacy
continues unhinged lie filled bizarre
endless statements almost completely
unintelligible this is not someone who
is well but he is by far as of today the
front runner to be the 2024 Republican
primary nominee I've said it before and
I will say it again sure
Trump's whacked out of his gourd I get
it but what does it say about his
followers that after everything that's
happened
he puts out these tirades these screeds
and it still allows him to maintain
support from many of the people who
supported him in 2020. it says more
about his followers than it says about
Trump
we're entering a sort of fascinating and
bizarre period of the Fox News
defamation text message Scandal and the
latest player in this insane theater Act
of sorts uh is Mark Levin Mark Levin is
often framed as I'm the serious guy on
Fox News I only do a weekly show because
I'm busy doing very serious things on
all of my other days and you can count
on forget about what happens on the
weekdays or during the day Sunday night
or wherever wherever whenever his show
is you're really going to get serious
stuff from me and so in the midst of
this defamation lawsuit from Dominion
voting systems against Fox News and the
leaked text messages wherein we find out
that even though Tucker Carlson is
pretending like he might be a believer
of the 2020 conspiracy theory that Trump
actually won behind the scenes he's
texting I hate Trump passionately and
this is crazy and our viewers don't know
the difference and it's on that okay in
the middle of all of that
Mark Levin without anyone forcing him to
do this he tells us in this segment
nobody told him to do this
he delivers a cringy and bizarre rant
defending Fox News okay let's take a
look at it
you know it's a great honor for me to
come to you every Sunday night on this
network the Fox News channel
and I want you to know something yeah I
could not do this show anywhere else on
cable on network TV and so forth because
is it that is it is it that bad Mark is
it such a bad show no one else would
have it jeez you wouldn't allow it I'm
sure
so several years ago Fox Mr Murdoch and
Suzanne Scott the CEO asked me if I
would do a show and you know he's really
honest right now because he took off his
glasses to deliver part of this they
didn't even ask me what kind of show
and I said okay let's do it I'd like to
do it on a Sunday night late I'd like to
see how we can do it a long form
interview
do what you can and do the best you can
and that's pretty much the only
direction I've ever been given wow
and so I tell you this for a reason when
I come here and do this program I
determine what I'm going to say in the
opening statement I determine who the
guests are going to be now understand
that it's not that when posts say that
it's not true but like it's meaningless
in the sense that the hosts at RT
remember when Russian propaganda TV was
on in the United States RT TV
and a really long time ago I appeared on
it as well until I decided like that's
I'm never doing that again it just it
doesn't it doesn't make it doesn't feel
right to be doing it but 12 years ago I
appeared on there a couple of times the
hosts there would always say no one ever
told me what to say here I I decided
what to say and as we previously
analyzed yeah okay that's that's fine
but what you have to understand is they
are screening for content by who they
hire you're only there because they know
you're already going to say things that
they're okay with so that phrase a lot
of these people when they work at a
propaganda Network whether it's RT or
Fox News they go no one comes here and
tells me nobody writes my monologue for
me
doesn't really mean that much
there were enough faith in me to know
that I'm not going to blow the place up
and this is very important to understand
because they treat all the hosts this
way they treat The Newsroom this way and
this fantastic Network yeah they don't
even care if The Newsroom lies they let
them do whatever they want if it didn't
exist I want you to think about what
kind of media you would be receiving day
in and day out
from Meet the Press from Good Morning
America from God knows what he's
comparing different types of programs in
order to make everything else seem
consumed by trivialities now of course
there's plenty of triviality on Fox News
as well it would just be the same thing
over and over again we really do have a
competition of ideas here even among
conservatives even within The Newsroom
and that's a good thing that's the way
it's supposed to be this is a vibrant
vigorous Network nobody asked me to tell
you this I just decided to say it yeah
there's nobody just off screen holding a
gun pointing at me tell you why
even though we come under attack here we
come under attack from the same sources
who have lied to you about so much and
continue to lie to you about so much
there are basically appendages of the
Democrat Party they're mouthpieces for
the left there's simply no question
about that
sounds pretty good I mean Fox News
sounds like a pretty great great place
right and remember nobody told him to
say this so the bottom line here is that
you can come at this from any angle you
want and use this pathetic speech to to
enter this discussion anywhere you want
to enter it Fox News has admitted in
court and under oath that they lie in
the sense that
when they're people like Tucker Carlson
or whoever say things it should be
understood that they are being
entertaining and using Hyperbole and
exaggeration for the sake of
entertainment not these are news people
delivering the most accurate uh version
of the facts that they are able to find
and you then work backwards from there
and you get to the defamation suit which
is partially the result of entertainers
making the ratings-based decision even
when they didn't believe a lot of this
stuff privately
to allow conspiracy theories on air
which allegedly bordered over into
defamation as far as Dominion voting
systems was concerned now we know that
there seemed to be some True Believers
at Fox News for example last week we
looked at text messages between Fox host
Maria Bartiromo and Stephen Bannon in
those texts it really seemed like Maria
Bartiromo was a True Believer but Tucker
was not Laura Ingram was not Sean
Hannity was not at least from the text
that were revealed whether that makes
Fox great or whether that makes Fox bad
or not news or news or whatever well
those are all different questions but
these sorts of speeches delusionally
defending Fox News as the last Bastion
of people being able to learn about the
world around them not only is it
pathetic and unhinged I don't even think
Mark Levin believes it to be perfectly
Frank
uh have a amazing clip of another one of
these Republican hearings backfiring
terribly every single one of these just
goes so so so wrong radical and
repugnant Republican congresswoman
Lauren bobert from Colorado
she was asking questions
to Kiran
ayusha I don't exactly know the right
pronunciation of the name but I hope
that that's close
um Kieran is the director of the U.S
office of personnel management and
Lauren bobert was going after her
because of the number of federal
employees not logging into work based on
2020 data the only problem 2020 was a
different Administration run by a guy
named Donald Trump you're not aware of
any employee taking something that one
would consider a vacation time and
bringing their computer and maybe
logging in just a portion of that time
or not at all we have we have more than
25 percent of federal employees not
longing not logging into work
and they're teleworking congresswoman I
do take issue with the characterization
that 25 percent of individuals are not
it's in this leaked document right here
that we just submitted into
you're the record you're basing that
from 2020 which is in the last
Administration and I can't speak to that
isn't that the best so first of all
bobert is trying to make a point with
data from a different Administration
okay that's funny but the really funny
point is despite all of her praise for
the Trump Administration the things
she's really angry about here the thing
that Lauren bobert is trying to pin on
Joe Biden's uh director of that agency
actually applies to her Lord and Savior
Donald Trump's Administration previously
it the this is not the first time that
this has happened a lot of these people
they talk about 2020. you know I I
genuinely don't know whether they're
just morons or whether they've forgotten
or they're confused I know that there
was a 2020 election
there was an election in 2020 but it
took place in November and the people
who won in November of 2020 didn't start
working until January of 2021 including
Joe Biden so they have many times a lot
of things didn't go great in 2020 you
might remember inflation was starting to
go up gas prices were going up all these
different things
and they go listen what look at these
numbers
look at what happened after Joe Biden
was here when he was elected in 2020
right but Biden wasn't in power until
the end of January of 2021 I don't know
if they're doing this on purpose to
deceive or whether they're clueless or
whether they're morons or some
combination of the above but it just
keeps happening again and again and
again we have a voicemail number that
number is 2192 David P here is the
Eggman calling in about yes my my cameo
in a Netflix documentary about Malaysian
Airlines flight 370 which I guess is
like one of the top things in the
country right now listen to this
hey I don't know if you mentioned this
on your program yet but yeah you know
that you're in the
MH370 the plane that disappeared as
documentary on Netflix yeah in the
second episode
um it says David Pacman cameo
I'm sure you know this I'm sure you've
already said that but um it's implying
like you're almost a conspiracy guy
about you know some patents or something
anyway it was really neat to see you
yeah on this Doc in the middle of the
night when I'm watching TV Shalom
brother yeah Shalom to the Eggman I hope
you had a good Purim listen
um I am probably tomorrow or the day
after gonna do a full segment about my
appearance in that documentary where
they absolutely make me sound like a
conspiracy theorist
by using a clip in which I am debunking
a conspiracy theory now I'm also not
going to blame anybody by by myself but
myself for what happened and I'm going
to explain all of this tomorrow but I am
not happy with the way in which I was
included in that I now know what I did
wrong
um a contract lawyer reached out to me
and we exchanged a couple of emails they
frame me as a conspiracy theorist using
a clip where I'm debunking a conspiracy
let's talk about it tomorrow or
Wednesday I will tell you what's going
on we have a fantastic bonus show for
you today Tucker Carlson's ex-producer
was worried about their quote dumb
viewers falling for the lies that they
were telling it's a fascinating Peak
behind the curtain a new poll suggests
that Ron desantis's anti-woke Crusade
might actually backfire on him and we
will talk about listen to this every
year daylight savings we talk about the
movement for permanent daylight savings
there's a movement against permanent
daylight savings and it's a different
perspective I'll explain to you what
they believe why we'll evaluate whether
it makes sense and then whatever I'll
take a nap because I'm tired from the
time change so that'll be the plan for
the bonus show I will nap during the
show which will be a new thing uh might
be interesting to some people sign up
for membership at joinpakman.com
you'll get instant access to the bonus
show
the commercial free audio and video
feeds of the show oh the bonus show
where you want to make money okay
everybody else that makes money to fund
themselves as bad all right all right
let's settle down uh and invitations to
member only Town Hall events the next of
which is coming up pretty soon sign up
at joinpakman.com I'll see you then
foreign